I'm a senior scientist here at the
Simons Institute and it's my pleasure to
invite you to the boot camp of the
analysis and TCS thing
all right okay so just a quick
introduction to the Simon's Institute
and then I'll hand it over to uh
um the session chair
um okay so Simon's Institute is the
leading international venue for
collaborative research in theory of
computing in related fields it was
established in 2012 with a very generous
Grant from the Simon's foundation and
every semester it hosts programs
um on topical themes which brings
together world's leading researchers in
the topic about 70 of them junior or
senior as well as the next generation of
outstanding Young Scholars and as I said
we typically run about two programs each
semester each attracting uh several
large cohort of long-term visitors as
well as short-term visitors who come for
workshops and so on and these days we
are also having regular summer
activities including full programs like
this one in analysis and TCS New
Frontiers
and just a reminder that the first
scientific programs ran in fall 2013 and
one of them was in fact on the topic of
real analysis in computer science so
this program is a particularly apt way
to round off 10 years of stimulating
programs which which have pushed the
frontiers of TCS in so many directions
resolving long-standing open problems as
well as opening up new directions of
inquiry and connections with other
fields so this week we kick off the
activities uh for the analysis and TCS
program with the bootcamp and the goal
here is to uh to acquaint program
participants with the key themes of the
program and it will consist of five days
of tutorial presentations on a variety
of topics related to the central themes
of the program and the tutorials given
by Leading experts and very active
researchers in the field
and so we have a large uh cohort of you
know distinguished organizers for the
program I'll quickly just mention their
names and I think some of them are here
already and some of them will be coming
in um you know we can various parts of
the program so they are nikhil bansal it
is
so big thanks to all the organizers and
uh I'd like to just quickly cover some
logistics for the coming week for the
um work you know the event itself now as
always all talks are live streamed so
people can watch on the YouTube thing
and for this particular Workshop it's
also uh in hybrid format so that is it's
also in webinar form so people you know
can also interact in a live way asking
questions
um remotely and the talks are also
recorded and posted on the Simon's
website and where they really enjoy a
life and impact long after the boot camp
finds talk and I think the boot camp
talks in particular have served as a
really valuable resource for students
and researchers worldwide to learn about
key results in a topic in a carefully
curated form so no pressure on the
speakers but you know you know you'll
have a long shelf life the talks this
week and very useful to people in all
corners of the world and about the
logistics itself so food is provided
outside uh before the first talk on
during the breaks just where you were
just before the thing for lunch you're
on your own but there are many excellent
is in walking distance and we ask that
you know you see that the auditorium is
excellent and you know really clean so
we ask your cooperation in keeping it
that way and that is and that's why we
insist that please leave all food
outside including coffee before coming
to talks if you want to leave some stuff
during lunch Etc there are lockers on
the other side of the room so you can
put your backpacks there and uh so our
videographer Omega far is around
throughout to help you with any AV
issues
um and I already mentioned the workshop
is hybrid so and the session chairs will
be requested to kind of monitor the
webinar answer relay questions to the
speaker Etc and finally a special thanks
to the events Team without whom none of
these events will happen and that's
Ashley Hassan and Elizabeth Ewan and for
managing all the logistics okay so I
think we should give them
will say a few words about the workshop
and also
yeah so uh this is on behalf of some of
the other organizers not everybody
should make it for today so why are we
holding this this program so I was part
uh um as well as your first Speaker of
the inaugural program 10 years ago
and since then and especially in the
recent like two or three years there
have been really spectacular
new ideas in the subject so in
particular uh Global hyperconductivity
High dimensional expanders luck on case
polynomials uh and and new and exciting
applications to um harness of estimation
so the goal of this program really is to
connect all of you to these recent
advances and the goal of this boot camp
is for you to um
got to know at least a little bit of of
this area so
you know sometimes uh the way that
mathematical talks are organized is that
you know the first five minutes are
understandable for everybody and then
the rest of the lecture is unsolvable by
nobody
so this is not not the uh the intent
here if there's something you don't
understand and probably these I know 100
people that uh Becca was talking about
that will watch this in the future will
also not understand so please do ask and
we're in no rush you know if there's
anything we can we don't cover then it's
in Ryan's book
okay so it's it's all fine
okay and I just want to remind you for
lunch today so there will be a reception
uh in the afternoon so please don't have
too much for lunch and with that I'd
like to introduce the first Speaker from
McGill
well it's going to start off this boot
camp thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right that was a good introduction
from you Val because I was worried that
uh I'm gonna have a pretty Elementary
talk about basics of the analysis of
Boolean functions and uh if you justify
that kind of That So you you're not
allowed to complain that this is too
boring
uh the other reason I'm gonna do an
elementary uh lecture is that there will
be later lectures about high-dimensional
expanders and things that I don't know
about and I want to set the president so
that they're not allowed to do very fast
and advanced uh talk
Okay so
William functions
let's start
looking at a Boolean functions
function that takes an n Bits sequence
of truths and falses and Maps it to true
and thoughts right now
uh we want to do analysis so we want to
move to something other than true and
fast where we can do analysis and this
is a dilemma I think anyone who
wants to present a course or a lecture
or write a book about Boolean functions
has like faces in the beginning so what
do we do with this true and false so
there are two options either two good
options
we work with the group Z2 to the N so
this one doesn't matter as much so I'm
just going to do 0 1 so this is option
one just view the Boolean Cube as the
group Z2 to the end the option two is to
work with
-1 1 to the end
now each one has advantages so every
time I've given a course on this topic
whenever I choose this Midway I regret
let's say I should have chosen this
because and there's some nice things
here and when you do this sometimes you
regret and so in I'm gonna pick this one
so the advantage of this one is that I
mean this is an abelian group and the
whole Theory generalizes to other
billion groups so
General let's say finite or even more
General locally finite obedient groups
so I'll present this as kind of a
general
like a lot of things I'm going to say
they're going to work for any general
like final Financial groups I'll mention
also sometimes it's better to work with
this one and this one has the advantages
too so one thing is that you don't
necessarily want need a group sometimes
so you work sometimes with General uh
product spaces so this could be just any
finite set to the power n so generalizes
to
like product spaces
and the other actually nicer property
when you work with this is that then
your functions you can view them as
multilinear polynomials also
see
polynomials and this is quite a nice
way of viewing these things because then
you can work with degree and those
things are become very natural
all right uh so yeah sometimes I'll move
to this one and take advantage of this
fact that these are you can view such a
function as a multilinear polymer
all right but for now we'll focus on
this one so we'll have
um so let G just be a finite abelian
group
so our basic setting is we got we are
interested in functions and these are
billion groups with as a Hilbert space
so if you're interested in uh set of
functions F from G to two complex values
because when you do to finite General
Pioneer billion groups then you have to
work with complex valued characters so
set up this
uh with the inner product
so Define the inner product as
here there is a choice of normalization
and I'm going to normalize it
with the probability measure so expected
value you pick X from G so this means X
is picked uniformly at random from G so
it's a probability measure here and f of
x g of X bar okay that's our inner
product
and
it is an inner product uh it has all the
properties the F and GR
the same
so you get a positive number if and only
if it's non-zero yeah
so you always get a positive number and
it's non-zero if f is non-zero and it's
linear in the first one and uh
conjugate linear in the second one okay
so we'll denote this space with once you
have an inner product you also get a
norm so this is a Hilbert space we'll
denote it by l12g and then corresponding
Norm is of course
it's gonna be
in our product of f by itself square
root which is that's the value of f of x
squared yes square root of this all
right so this is the space we are
interested in uh here
now now let's move to Fourier analysis
which is one of the main tools that's
used to analyze uh Boolean functions at
least in the area and as what's called
analysis of Boolean functions or Ryan's
book as you all mentioned
Okay so
the key definition that starts this
thing is uh we Define the characters of
this a billion group
function
I from G to C
all the character
um if it is basically a group morphism
um with the product yeah
uh yeah so yeah you get a non-zero I
should have mentioned
um yeah like let's remove Zero from here
yeah
yeah so the first uh so basically this
means that zero has to go to the zero
with the product here so
when you take the zero element of the
group it has to go to one which is the
zero element here which product and the
second property is that
five okay plus b becomes again the group
product there you just have a Times
Square okay so these two properties if
you satisfy this and your function is
non-zero we call that a character so so
far it's pretty abstract right it's like
we don't really know what these
functions are
um
so
what is a trivial example of a character
it's just the constant function one
so if you look at just one
is always a character no matter what
group you pick
and we call this the principal character
so this is always a character of any
group you pick it's just the constant
function one obviously math zero to one
and it's multiplicative in this sense
um
okay so let's try to understand these
characters a bit more
uh one thing is at least in this setting
because G is finite
um
so pick any
element in the group because G is finite
there will be some if you add uh I mean
a is going to be a finite order so if uh
if you add a enough times you're gonna
get zero
then there exists sum and such that
an a which is just a plus
okay it's going to be zero okay so
because just find it eventually you have
to repeat and that gives you some n that
gives you zero and now with this let's
uh see what we get using this second
property here so we're gonna have that
hi uh if you add a enough times
which is by this second property it's
just Chi of a the power n so this is
supposed to be
Phi of zero which we know it's one
so what does this tell us it tells us
that
for every element in the group like Chi
is gonna be a root of unity right so
so what we got is the chi of a and for
some n is one so
Okay so
uh so even though we Define the
character as functions to all complex
numbers what happens is that they always
go only to the unit complex Circle so we
can say that
every character is goes from G to this
unit complex circles T is d
in a circle under
okay so we understand them a little bit
more it's not just general value complex
numbers
um
now uh
a very important properties of
characters that how you can combine it
and it turns out that character if you
look at the characters of G those
actually form another group so let me
write this
the theorem G
finite
Union group
then
the set of characters of G
or an abelian Group which is called the
Dual group of G
okay
let's see why
um
so
this uh group is a billion and its zero
element is going to be just the
principal character so
zero
principle character
one because obviously one times any
character is character times one which
is chi
so that's our zero element uh what is
the other property we need to show you
need to show that the product of two
character is also a character so if you
have two characters Chi and PSI
if you multiply them
and you look at it as some element A
plus b
foreign
by definition this is a plus b times
a plus b which now you can use this to
expand this and regroup them so
so
uh
yeah so if you have two characters if
you multiply them Point wise you're
going to get another character
um and then the inverse element so what
is I mean this is an appealing group so
you need an inverse for every element
and what is the inverse of chi that's
going to be just the conjugate hash
so
got that Chi times conjugate is one of
course because these are these go to the
units complex Circle and Chi bar is also
a character obviously and Pi Bar of a
plus b
yes it's just
sorry I know this is blocking some of
you but I'm assuming you know this stuff
uh okay so yeah the
the set of characters they form a group
here
and
um
I mean one thing I'm not going to prove
here is that this dual group is actually
going to be isomorphic to the original
group so for for all these for the
finite a billion group so this is only
in the finite case
foreign
it's kind of easy to prove because we
know what finite a billion groups are
they're just products of uh zns so we
can actually list their characters and
see that they're isomorphic but one
thing I want to mention is that because
of this I I'm gonna often
denote the characters by
because you have this isomorphism here
so I'm gonna use often Chi a to denote
a character or the character
responding to an element a in G so this
one is in G hat okay so this is a
notation
yeah surfing one specific
so that there's one isomorphism so it's
uh I'm sorry uh we need to choose a
primitive
for each
uh because there's no like specific
Natural Choice yeah
uh that's true but you can pick any and
uh
should we predicted to the end there is
uh yeah but for Zippy to or for the
other ones
that's I mean uh once I list the
characters the size of orphism becomes
clear that which one I'm gonna use okay
so yeah
yeah it's a bit maybe too early to
mention this notation at this point once
you list the characters you also get
this
um okay
now the most useful property of this
character is for us is that they form an
uh
orthonormal basis for this L2 of G
okay so this is what we are aiming to
show now that the set
characters
Jihad
forms an orthonormal basis
or L2 of G okay so they're gonna be so
each character is going to be a unit
Vector in this space and they're going
to be orthogonal so let's try to show
this
um all right
so the key I mean it's a very simple
proof and it's quite nice without
actually telling you what the characters
are we can prove this and
at least the orthogonality
so you start with this Lemma that if Chi
is a non-principle character
and when you add
I over the elements of G you're gonna
always get zero okay
uh so let's prove this it's
quite easy so pick
any element let's say y
oh G
and let's look at let's shift this sum
by y so let's look at
sum of
let me do it this way so
if I shift all these X's by y I'm gonna
still have a sum over G right it's just
it's just reordering the sum so I can
write this as the sum of
X and G I have X Plus Y and now I can
use the multiplicative
property of this Chi and write this as
a y
times the sum
okay
[Music]
all right so we showed that there is
so this we showed it it's true for
everyone
so what do we get from this so either
this Chi y has to be one for every y
in which case we get a principal
character so that can't be the case
since cut since there exists some y such
as Chi Y is not one
we get that this sum has to be zero
right because we got the sum equals to
this number times the same thing so
it's the end of the proof okay so really
we don't even know need to know what the
characters are but to get this property
from that
and now we can prove that
the fact that these characters are
orthogonal
so core and say this is a corollary if
I can let's say PSI are characters
then
zero if they're not the same characters
and
um one
otherwise so we get that they're
orthonormal
so why is this um
okay so let's look at this inner product
side this is expected value of x
r
of X right uh I mean
we saw that the product of two first of
all this is the inverse of PSI as a
character
and when you multiply you get a new
character which is the sky sidebar
now we can apply this this expected
value is just
sum it's 1 over G sum X
G
X now we can apply the Lemma because
this is the this is a character so
either is the principal character
dilemma
either this is just one in which case we
get this case
or the sum is zero right uh or the
expected value
okay so we get
if this is a non-principle character
this whole thing becomes zero so the
expected value is zero we are in this
case
and if this is one it just means Chi is
always equal to psi which is this case
and we get one because all these terms
are one and the expected value is one
okay so again without even knowing what
the characters are we get this uh thing
that they're orthogonal
um
now one thing actually I don't know if
anyone here knows how to show that uh if
you want to show this is an orthonormal
basis you also have to show that there
is enough of them I mean so you need to
have you know the same number of
characters that's the same as G because
this is a g-dimensional space
so one way to show that is to use this
but I don't know any like any way like
prove it like this without actually
going into how this correspondence works
but but anyway so because of this we
also know that we have exactly the right
number of characters so they actually
form an orthonormal bases so they expand
the whole Space
yeah exactly so yeah maybe there is no
proof like this look simple proof
uh okay
so let's say yeah I haven't quite
defined so that's what I was saying it
kind of maybe uh I should have waited to
denote that uh so once I tell you
how they look these characters for
finite typically in groups you get this
nice one-to-one correspondence and we'll
do it differently for Z2 to the end and
yeah so there is a natural
correspondence that you go like from g
to g hat which gives you
choices
from the case of uh yeah
okay so now we have this orthonormal
basis for Electro so l2g we have two
natural bases for it
so the one basis which corresponds to
what's called like physical space what
we usually work with when you're not
doing query analysis is uh
so the basis is going to be these
functions the
Mass Point function basically Delta a
Maps X to 1
X is a that's zero otherwise
this is for every
in G so this is just the chord like the
points of the function right so you can
write your function
f as sum of a and g
um f of a
times these functions Delta a which
picture so this is the when you work
with the function and the values and the
points you're working with this in the
physical space but now we have now that
we have this other basis the Fourier
basis we can also move to this other
space which I'll call say Fourier space
now you can have a different expansion
for f in this character basis so I can
write f as
some now the sum is going to be over the
characters
or other orthonormal basis
and you have the character and then you
have to put a coefficient here and the
coefficient we're going to denote it by
this F hat so F hat of chi times Chi so
this is
a different like we're moving into a
different base that's right to the to
the character basis so this is what we
call the Fourier expansion of f
of F and
what are these coefficients how do we
calculate the coefficients we can just
take the inner product of f with any
character and that will cancel
everything except the the character
right so except this corresponding
coefficients so if Chi is going to be
just F
the pi times Chi is going to be only one
for that one this exactly this character
for everything else we get zero so they
cancel
okay so these are the coefficients that
we get
[Music]
foreign
so now we have this transform that takes
F and takes returns as a function on G
hat
which is this the set of these
coefficients and this is a linear
transformation so note that
this map that takes F which is a
function from G to C and Maps it to this
other function f hat which is a function
and G hat to see
it's a linear transformation
okay so if you add two functions it's
going to be added if you scale F
multiply F by some Lambda these are
going to be multiplied by Lambda
um because
so
this transformation has some Key
Properties so that's what we're going to
look at next and that comes from
first of all
identity
so here maybe I'll write this as it's
going from L2 of G
L to uh
uh so what is pastel's identity let's
look at the inner product of f by itself
so
let me write this as
a two Norm of f squared which is the
expected value of
x squared which is the inner product of
f
now actually maybe
do a different normalization there
uh okay so that was what we had the norm
on this space but now if I take this and
take the inner product of f by itself
so what do we get
I mean this was just a linear algebra
really right so pull your hair so this
is the product of these two sums in our
product of these two sums
and these are orthonormal so what we're
gonna get here is exactly like
everything cancels except when clients
are the same so this is going to be the
sum over
because we get one and this is f hat F
hat conjugate so it becomes
that thing
so
so we started with this average of f of
x square and we ended up with the sum of
these F hat squares right which looks
very similar except they have a
different normalization here it's an
expected value so everything like the
sum is divided by the size of G but here
it's just a sum
so now what does this tell us it tells
us if you look at this as a function
from L2 of G to
small L2 of G so this is just uh the
norm is defined with sum instead of
expected value this is a unitary
operation like it preserves the norm
right it takes so
like that
here
foreign
what we showed is that the expected
value of f of x
squared is the same as the sum of square
or
another word
uh in other words if you look at the L2
of
a two Norm of F this is the same as
so the L2 Norms remain the same when you
do it's a unitary operation uh and this
is quite useful because
it tells us that it doesn't matter if
your work if you're just interested in
the L2 Norm it doesn't matter if you're
working with physical space or free
space so you can go back and forth and
when you do free analysis A lot of it is
that you try to
relate things
like even if you're naturally your
problem is something about L1 Norm of
air for some LP normal for different P
you try to move to L2 and then you can
move to Fourier and back so there's a
lot of
these things that especially for Boolean
functions there are zeros and ones so
when you
expected value of f is the same as say
expected value of f squared so you
always want to go to a square to uh to
be able to move to the L2 and then you
can just easily move to the previous
space and back
okay so now
yeah
wouldn't you get the same should you get
the sum of
the base
like in the physical space yeah why is
it an expectation
that's how we Define l property right so
that
the thing is like the characters if you
define them going to to unit complex
that's gonna create this problem that
somehow you're gonna need a different
normalization I mean when you do the
inner product you see right like you
you're expanding this so you're gonna
get a sum even though this thing was
defined and expected value and maybe we
can give a privilege character
so that if you take a trivial characters
and the function has
then different people have different
organizations yeah exactly so one thing
we can do is actually you can
you can L2 space then when you go to the
other one it changes so it's it's a
little bit annoying because it's really
like a different paper you papers you
see that some people just work with some
instead of expected value and then you
get these factors of G appearing and
sometimes yeah this one is
I like this one better because
you don't see at least you don't have to
normalize things multiplying the size of
G it doesn't appear but then the reason
we're there is often our functions are
zero one or plus minus one again it
makes a lot of sense yeah
all right so now I mean so far
everything was just abstract so let's
look at
our favorite groups this is again let's
see what characters
for this
foreign
so for this one for every
a in Z2 to the n
we have this character so Chi a little
saying so this is gonna be just it Maps
X to minus one
the sum of a i
x i
okay and
small character here is
I have zero which is just maps of course
every X to because all these AIS are
zero so it just gets mapped to one okay
right so here are the correspondence
that we get so for every
um sort of diss notation for every A and
Z to the N you just look at those X I's
where a i is
one and you add those up right this AIS
are either zero or one so the zero ones
basically gets dropped from this sum
and the rest we add up so
another way to denote this uh characters
which is very common and useful
is using the set notation because
exactly we are only interested in the
coordinates the cell one so
you can say for every
subset
a 1 to n
I'm gonna map
so I can use the subset notation for
this in case of Z2 to the end this makes
sense
minus one
and in this case
I have the empty set is that principle
cache
okay so here s is basically that those
eyes where a i is one because the zero
ones you don't see them in the sum right
so that's exactly what you get here so
this is also a very common notation in
uh when you work with the Boolean Cube
and especially when you do -1 1 as we'll
see this is maybe more natural
okay maybe it's a good time to also
mention
it's the general case
thank you
all right so I'll just mention the zp
and then the other ones are just
products of this so for zp
so mod P basically what we have is
foreign
X to
e to the 2 pi I divided by P times
ax
okay so this this is where we get this
minus one when P equals to 2 but for the
other ones you're going to get a complex
number
uh and then when you have the product of
these things similar to this case you
just like multiply so that's the general
case uh right so that's the notation of
C I'm gonna use
so one thing that comes up so I want to
just it's a little bit of a intuition
thing is uh when you look at these
characters let's see in this case so
let's say p is a big number and let's
look at these characters how do they
look
uh at least in terms of the magnitude
when
a is a small
so first of all when a is zero what do
we get it's the principal character
right so when a is zero we're gonna get
just
one everywhere so let's say
and then when a is small
will have some low frequency function
right so it's
it's
gonna be
um what's the either
or the complex
so
um so um yeah let's say I say if you
look at the real part of this character
it's going to be
I'll think of low frequency and as a
increases it becomes a higher frequency
so when a is large
you're gonna get something more
foreign
with higher frequency so when you write
this free expansion you're expressing
your function in terms of these waves
basically like low frequency versus high
frequency so that's pretty clear when
you're doing uh over zp or integers but
what about this uh Boolean Cube case so
in the Boolean Cube case
our functions really they just go to
ones and minus ones right so the range
and they are real valued actually
there's no complex so here the the
intuition so the same intuition will
translate to the size of f so one good
way to think about this is that so when
size of s is zero
again you just have the
the one it's one everywhere
and when size of s is a small
it is kind of a good intuition to think
of these as low frequency so
even though you don't really have this
kind of waves
and why is this like where is this
coming from is that if you look at this
thing when s is small let's say s is of
size one then this function just depends
on one coordinate right it just looks at
those let's say s is the size one and
they say one only the element one in s
then you're just looking at minus one to
x one so it's not very sensitive it only
looks at one coordinate and if you
change that it changes but let's say if
this s is full it's everything then this
is a kind of it's the parity function
it's very wild like any change you make
it's gonna change right so it's kind of
like this very small changes any small
change is going to change the function
so because of this it's often when you
have this free expansion it's quite
useful to break it into two parts so a
lot of these bounds that you get using
free analysis you partition your
function into
so you you can partition into different
levels basically so
so you look at say s where size of s is
less than t for some T that you pick if
you look at this hepat of
Sky S Plus The High Frequency part of it
which is yes
yeah so I mean I think tomorrow
you all will talk about
hyperconductivity and applications and
you'll see this kind of thing that when
you want to handle your function you
really divide it in two parts and handle
them differently so this is kind of more
like constant part of if it's low
frequency it's not very sensitive and
these are very sensitive so you have to
handle them differently yeah
in groups is there also like economical
way to say like what is low frequencies
right yeah exactly there is kind of so
uh I mean General appealing groups are
any aberian group looks like this right
so
if you want
okay so there's a nice crack translation
so you really look at one is like the
size of this A's that matters and how
many of them are announced so you can
say add the L1 of those and it just
tells you how sensitive they are to
change related to the earphones time
decomposition
for General product spaces let me know
yeah yeah so a lot of these things also
generalize to not like non-groove
settings not just general product spaces
and yeah again yeah
um okay
oh so yeah maybe
a little bit time left from this lecture
uh I'll also tell you
maybe this notation that polynomial
representation which is quite useful a
lot of time
so if we move our setting to F being
this function from -1 1 to b n we'll say
to C or just do Boolean is doing here
um now I don't really need to raise this
minus one to this power because now
actually my entries are ones and minus
one so I can just multiply them so in
this setting you can think of chi S as
just mapping X to
right you just multiply them you don't
need to raise minus one to those Powers
so your Fourier representation becomes
really just a polynomial ability so this
is a monomial
so multilinear
you don't have any power larger than one
so that's the multi-linear part of the
linear monomial of degree
by the s
so this F becomes
and so this is the unique
near representation of
f so another way to define
Fourier in this case it's not for you
anymore it's just a polynomial
representation yeah you just look at the
polynomial representation of a unique
polynomial representation of refwork the
monomials are multilinear you don't have
any power larger than one yeah and
that's unique so
yeah and then uh I mean these are now
polynomials so we can we know a lot
about polynomials
and
also now you can think about things like
degree so things like degree of f
becomes a natural
which is the
maximum of
size of s with
being
empty
sorry non-zero
okay so we can ask what are the
Boolean functions of certain degree or I
mean it's a natural thing that comes up
and
parameter
I think I'll stop here it's a good place
to stop and then in the next hour I'll
Define convolution and then we'll
actually apply this so any questions
yeah
um foreign
I mean the the most basic thing you can
do for a function is look at its average
right the expected value of f versus say
the rest of it so F minus expected value
with right so the density of say if f is
the indicator function of of a set then
you break the density versus the
non-density part and this is kind of a
bit moving a bit more where it's not
just density you look also at the lower
frequencies and uh
I mean it's it's at least in this that
case like in the zp case you if you have
something like if you're shifting your
function X by some a then these kind of
things becomes quite useful right like
you so you now you're applying Chi
so when you look at the Korea expansion
you're looking at this Chi X plus a
and now low frequency ones behave
they're kind of a stable under these
small shifts if a is the small number
let's just say one
right so those ones don't change much
where the large ones change a lot and
the same with the
in the Boolean case also if if you say
you pick a random coordinate and you
shift then the low ones are more likely
not to change because they're pretty
stable whereas the high ones gonna have
more likely to change so in this kind of
problems yeah it's very useful to break
it like this
the character is like the part of the
function that depends only on S
yeah and this you can do in let's say
gaussian space or whatever
and on the other end you have the
division into levels which tells you for
example how noise density your function
is this is uh we'll see that later we'll
say complexity influence whatever and
this makes sense even and when you don't
really have a nice basis
so it's a correlation of different
things and lastly like this character
aspective linearity testing yeah
several different things combined
together
thank you
any other questions
all right so see you in half an hour
[Applause]
so we'll get back here in half an hour
if